ecco il pane quotidiano
una delle 15mila onlus che distribuisce
circa 3.000 pasti al giorno insieme ad
altre 15 mila onlus in italia
lì di fronte ogni mattina troverete una
lunga lunghissima fila di persone che
sono alla ricerca di un pasto caldo il
pane quotidiano si occupa insieme ad
altre migliaia di associazioni di 6
milioni di italiani che vivono in una
condizione di povertà assoluta ma ci
siamo mai chiesti davvero che cosa
significa povertà assoluta
vive in una condizione di povertà
assoluta
una persona che soffre di una carenza di
risorse tale da mettere addirittura
repentaglio la propria vita
parallelamente pensate che secondo uno
studio del barilla center for food and
nutrition
il valore totale dello spreco alimentare
solo in italia ha raggiunto
l'astronomica cifra di 37 miliardi di
euro secondo la coldiretti 44 milioni di
italiani potrebbero essere alimentati
nutriti attraverso le derrate alimentari
che quotidianamente sprechiamo signore
stiamo parlando di un'altra italia
alimentata attraverso i nostri sprechi
perciò spreco alimentare da una parte
bisogno urgente dall'altra qui abbiamo
il modo per connetterle
si chiama breaking up grading è
un'applicazione che si pone come
obiettivo quello di limitare lo spreco
alimentare per ri destinare alle
migliaia di associazioni che
quotidianamente si occupano di povertà
questi eccessi branding è
un'applicazione il cui nome deriva da
brad pane un nome inglese ed è un
progetto nato qualche mese fa tra
bergamo e milano con la convinzione che
il digitale debba essere una svolta
concreta e positiva nella nostra società
vogliamo creare una app che sia un ponte
tra negozianti associazioni
vogliamo creare una rete che trasformi
questo piano virtuale questo piano di
cellulari che utilizziamo tutti i giorni
in aiuti concreti e quotidiani
ma come funziona davvero branding
ecco luca luca un panettiere che tutti i
giorni a crea pane pane di qualità
vorrebbe aiutare luca il territorio in
cui vive perché è un territorio che da
anni fa vivere bene lui è luca tutti i
giorni alle 17 30 fa una stima del pane
avanzato ma quando brad in sarà
operativa
luca il pane non lo butterà più luca
infatti sarà iscritto avrai ding
prenderà il suo smartphone e nella
piattaforma inserirà il quantitativo di
cibo avanzato nel suo profilo inoltre
luca avrà inserito l'indirizzo del suo
panificio e proprio per questo dovrà
semplicemente aspettare che qualcuno
passi a ritirarlo e voi vi chiederete
ornella ma qualcuno chi matteo matteo è
un giovane studente un giovane studente
che presta servizio presso
un'associazione un paio di volte alla
settimana
un'associazione che ha la sede
ho più vicina al panificio di luca luca
in realtà non lo sa
matteo avrai scritto anche gli a
l'associazione al branding e proprio per
questo motivo riceverà una notifica sul
suo cellulare contenente tutti i
dettagli del degli avanzi del panificio
di luca grazie alla geolocalizzazione
luca troverà matteo alla sua porta e gli
darà gli avanzi della giornata e matteo
poi tornerà all'associazione e prestera
servizio alla mensa
in questo modo cosa sarà successo che
luca avrà dato tutto il prodotto della
giornata e quindi avrà evitato gli
sprechi mentre invece matteo e la sua
onlus avranno in questo modo risparmiato
i soldi per l'acquisto delle derrate
alimentari che potranno così investire
in altri in altri servizi da dare alla
comunità
secondo lo slot che è un concetto di
valore che permette di monetizzare
quelli che sono gli impatti dei progetti
che hanno un impatto sociale e
ambientale
noi sappiamo che branding per la sola
città di milano per ogni singolo euro
che andremo ad investire all'interno
della società porterà 18 euro per la
sola città di milano
ora ad oggi non abbiamo ancora
l'applicazione stiamo arrivando a quello
che è il cuore del progetto
l'app è la nostra visione è quella di
renderla disponibile su tutti i sistemi
operativi
parallelamente a una web app ea un
sistema sms
nonostante la non sia ancora operativa
però pensate che abbiamo già ricevuto
decine di richieste da commercianti e
associazioni
dal piccolo paesino della valle d'aosta
ma anche dalla grande capitale romana e
oggi siamo qua a chiedere a voi quelle
che sono le vostre competenze e a
chiedere a voi un aiuto perché quello
che vogliamo è creare un'applicazione
che sia subito realizzabile e che possa
raggiungere tutti tutti quei sei milioni
di persone che vivono in una condizione
di povertà assoluta per fare in modo che
davvero non ci sia bisogno di corsi per
capirla ma che tutti quanti possano
possono capirla senza bisogno di
interfacce strane e che possiamo
direttamente leggerla accendere il
cellulare e capirla utilizzarla ora
quello che noi vogliamo fare trasformare
quelli che erano disegni di ipotesi
matteo luca in volti in carne ed ossa e
vogliamo fare in modo che questa
applicazione trasformi numeri e speranze
in cibo e pane trasportato dal calore
umano in fondo alla tecnologia solo un
mezzo sono le persone che la utilizzano
che fanno la differenza
grazie